This is how the marine language uses
sound and bubbles
rather than words to communicate.
I'm Legom, a hen.
Because we're seated alphabetically,
I'm sitting next to a dull male wolf.
He always looks stumped
with drooping brows,
so I call him a brow-knitter.
The brow-knitter and I are not that close,
but I know one of his secrets.
Class dismissed.
Review today's lesson thoroughly.
You really like egg sandwiches.
It tastes the best on Wednesday.
No way. They're all the same.
No, they're different.
I can't explain it, though.
It's too good to be sold at school.
Right? Of course it is.
The egg sandwich he snacks on
every Wednesday,
those eggs are, in fact, laid by me.
EGG SUPPLY ROSTER (LEGOM)
I sell my eggs to restaurants on campus
as a part-time job.
I take great pride in this job.
Hey, Legom.
I'm having a movie night tonight.
Do you want to come?
Thanks for the invite, but I'll pass.
Staying up too late would be
bad for my eggs.
What? It's just a part-time job,
take it easy.
You're wrong.
Laying eggs is not a mere part-time job.
I'm doing this for our dignity
and pride of all henkind.
Excuse me.
I even started exercising, which is my
least favorite, for a mere part-time job.
Don't worry. I'm not upset.
Legom.
I'm not doing this to provide
carnivores with necessary protein.
It's for nobody else but me.
I'll keep laying high-quality eggs.
That, for sure, is my beautiful life.
JUNE 16, WEDNESDAY
Hey, Legoshi.
Today's Wednesday,
where's your egg sandwich?
It tastes different these days.
I told you, they're all the same.
Maybe...